AND THE ECONOMIC PLAN.
TRACE, LET'S GET TO OUR GUEST.
>> Trace: PRESIDENT BIDEN
FACING FIRE FROM ALL SIDES OVER
THE BORDER CRISIS.
THE CAMP UNDER THE BRIDGE NOW
NEARLY EMPTY.
JOINING US WITH MORE TEXAS
CONGRESSMAN DAN CRENSHAW.
I KNOW YOU LISTENED TO THE
PRESIDENT MOMENTS AGO.
I WAS STUNNED AT THE TALKING
ABOUT THE BORDER AGENTS AND
SAYING THINGS THAT ARE NOT TRUE.
WE LOOKED AT THE VIDEO,
ANALYSTS LOOKED AT THE VIDEO.
THERE WERE NO WHIPS USED ON
THESE PEOPLE AND YET YOU HAVE
PEOPLE IN THE ADMINISTRATION,
INCLUDING THE PRESIDENT,
CONTINUING TO PROPAGATE THIS.
>> Dana: WE HAVE THAT SOUND.
CAN WE PLAY THAT SOUND AND HAVE
YOU REACT TO IT, PLEASE?
>> President Biden: TO SEE
PEOPLE TREATED LIKE THEY DID.
HORSES RUNNING OVER AND PEOPLE
BEING STRAPPED IS OUTRAGEOUS, I
PROMISE YOU, THOSE PEOPLE WILL
PAY.
THERE WILL BE AN INVESTIGATION
AND THERE WILL BE CONSEQUENCES.
>> Dana: HE ALSO SAID IT WAS AN
EMBARRASSMENT AND DANGEROUS AND
WRONG, CONGRESSMAN.
>> YOU KNOW, THAT WAS PROBABLY
THE PART OF HIS SPEECH IN THE
LAST 30 MINUTES THAT MADE ME
THE MOST ANGRY.
WE COULD TAKE AN AIR DEBUNKING
ALL THE LIES HE TOLD ON ALL
DIFFERENT SUBJECTS.
THERE WAS A LOT.
THIS ONE WAS EGREGIOUS.
THE ONLY PEOPLE HE WANTS TO
HOLD ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE MESS
AT THE BORDER IS HIS OWN BORDER
AGENTS FOR DOING THEIR JOB.
HE PUT THEM IN THIS POSITION
AND LIES ABOUT WHAT THEY ARE
DOING.
HE LIESZ ABOUT THEIR ACTIONS.
CAN'T IMAGINE A WORSE LEADER
RIGHT NOW.
IF YOU TRY TO GET A MASS EXODUS
FROM THE BORDER PATROL AND QUIT
AND LOSE MORALE THIS IS A GREAT
WAY TO DO IT.
TO BLAME THEM.
YOU KNOW WHO ELSE ISN'T HELD
ACCOUNTABLE?
ALL THE PEOPLE ILLEGALLY
CROSSING OUR BORDER.
ALL THE UNVACCINATED AND THE
PEOPLE WITH COVID.
ALL THE PEOPLE INFILTRATING OUR
COUNTRY AND LYING ABOUT THEIR
ASYLUM CLAIMS.
THEY AREN'T HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
BUT BIDEN DOESN'T CARE ABOUT
THAT.
LOOK, WE HAVE TO STOP
PRETENDING IT ISN'T COMPETENCE.
THEY'RE DOING IT ON PURPOSE.
MAYORKAS WAS ON THE RECORD
YESTERDAY BRAGGING ABOUT HOW
THERE IS TOO MANY OF TRUMP'S
POLICIES THAT THEY'VE RESCINDED
TO EVEN COUNT.
THEY RESCINDED ALL THESE
POLICIES AND ACT SURPRISED IT
CAUSED A MASS MIGRATION ABOUT
THE BORDER.
AND THEY ACT LIKE IT IS JUST A
TOUGH SITUATION THAT THEY HAVE
TO DEAL WITH.
BUT IT IS NOT.
IT WAS DONE ON PURPOSE.
>> Trace: AND I GUESS THAT'S
THE QUESTION AS YOU LOOK AT
THIS CONGRESSMAN AND YOU TALK
ABOUT WHAT THE PRESIDENT IS
SAYING AND YOU LOOK DOWN AT THE
BORDER AND WE'VE BEEN TRYING
NOW FOR A COUPLE OF DAYS TO GET
SECRETARY MAYORKAS AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO GIVE US
NUMBERS, RIGHT?
WE KNOW THERE ARE 3500 OF THOSE
HAITIAN IMMIGRANTS DOWN UNDER
THAT BRIDGE IN DEL RIO, TEXAS.
WE KNOW ABOUT 1800, 1400 HAVE
BEEN TAKEN BACK TO HAITI.
WE DON'T KNOW HOW MANY WERE
RELEASED INTO THE UNITED STATES.
BUT IT IS IN THE THOUSANDS AND
WE CANNOT GET EXACT NUMBERS AND
YET WE KNOW THEY DO HAVE THE
NUMBERS.
>> WELL, IT GETS WORSE THAN
THAT.
EVERYBODY IS FOCUSED ON THE
HAITIANS RIGHT NOW.
THESE ARE MOSTLY SINGLE MEN.
IT IS EASIER TO DEPORT THEM
UNDER TITLE 42 OR OTHER
IMMIGRATION LAWS.
EVERYBODY IS FOCUSED ON THAT
NOW.
DON'T LOSE SIGHT OF THE FACT
THAT WELL OVER A MILLION
ENCOUNTERS HAVE OCCURRED THIS
YEAR.
AND THEY WON'T GIVE US NUMBERS
ON HOW MANY OF THEM HAVE BEEN
RELEASED.
THAT WILL BE IN THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS.
OVER THE MILLION.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
THE EIGHTH LARGEST CITY IN
AMERICA.
THAT MEANS A POPULATION THE
SIZE OF THE EIGHTH LARGEST CITY
IN AMERICA HAS INFILTRATED OUR
COUNTRY AND THIS ADMINISTRATION
DOESN'T KARAT.
IT IS A DERELICTION OF
CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY.
HE IS WILLINGLY REFUSING AND
DELIBERATELY REFUSING TO
ENFORCE LAWS.
>> Dana: THANK YOU FOR WATCHING
SPEECH WITH US AND BEING THE
FIRST WE REACT TO IT.